one of the most pervasive stereotypes
about black Americans is that of the
absent black father the absent black
father myth is the idea the
stereotypical incorrect notion that
african-american fathers have very
little contact with their children if
any contact at all and in black America
the reality of being fatherless is
perhaps most painful 73 percent of all
black babies are born out of wedlock
experts say there's a crisis crisis when
it comes to black fathers in this
country the news media loves asking
where all the black fathers are and that
whole idea has been linked to everything
from poverty and crime to even police
violence against black communities why
are these police shootings occurring
well it's because there is an absent
black father or it's because black
families are on welfare but this idea
that black fathers aren't present in
their kids lives is actually false to be
a parent is to have children that you
love and try and support and black
fathers experience that the same way
that anyone else would why would you
even think there was a difference hey
guys I'm Senna and this Sunday on aj+
we're gonna talk about the myth of the
absent black father here in the United
States where it comes from and how that
stereotype tells a much bigger story
about the black family and black
communities in this country
[Music]
just because the trope of the absent
black father is so pervasive doesn't
mean it's true now yes according to a
Centers for Disease Control report in
2013 72 percent of non-hispanic black
women who gave birth were unmarried but
being an unmarried mother doesn't
automatically mean that the father isn't
involved and in fact that's exactly what
that CDC report found when compared to
whiter Hispanic fathers black fathers
were actually more likely to be involved
in their children's lives in almost
every way they were even more likely to
have bathed diaper or dress their kids
eaten a meal with them played with them
help them with homework and taken them
to and from activities and a lot of that
held true even when black fathers didn't
live with their children but if we go
solely off of what we see in the news
media where's dad don't really know tell
me about this you wouldn't really see
black fathers in that way communications
professor travis dixon studies the
prevalence of stereotypes in mass media
and the impact of these stereotypes on
audiences he wrote this report a
dangerous distortion of our families and
energy found that almost all news and
opinion media implicitly or explicitly
encourages pretty egregious assumptions
about black fathers black fathers were
shown spending time with their kids only
half as often as white fathers contrary
to well the actual facts we found that
black mothers white mothers white
fathers interacted with their kids about
26 percent of the time in these videos
and photos that occurred in the news
media half as often we found that
happening for black fathers only about
14% of the time where black fathers
actually interacting with their kids on
camera in photos
Dixon also found that news commentary
singled out black fathers 60% of the
time compared to white fathers only 20%
of the time what has it been like since
her dad spending
can a father's love breaks through
prison walls that media distortion is
substantial we know for a fact that
african-american fathers are just as
likely to participate in the lives of
their children than fathers of other
races and this isn't by the way a
politically partisan issue both
conservative news outlets like Fox News
and more centrist ones like CNN were top
distorter z' specifically Hannity the
Kelly file and CNN tonight did both of
you have fathers present in your lives
growing up so where does this toxic idea
about black father's even come from well
one theory takes it back to a 1965
report titled the Negro family the case
for national action the report became
one of the most contentious political
documents in twentieth-century America
Democrat an Assistant Secretary of Labor
Daniel Patrick Moynihan put the report
together to make the argument for how
the lyndon b johnson administration had
to do more for racial equality than
simply pass the Voting Rights Act
Moynihan argued that to really fight
racial inequality the government had to
understand the state of black
communities and why they were the way
they were but Moynihan ended up focusing
on one thing the black family according
to him the fundamental reason for
growing economic inequality between
white and black Americans was a
crumbling family structure in black
communities and at the foundation of the
so called crumbling black family
structure was the absent black father
Moynihan looked at non-marital birth
rates and rates of father's living
separately from their children and made
a whole bunch of assumptions about
parents relationship statuses and
parental involvement the report didn't
take into account factors like the
legacy of slavery generational wealth or
even economic migration in which men
left their home so that they could
provide for their families we spoke to
Carvel Wallace a writer and a podcaster
about the way black families have been
discussed in the mainstream reading some
of the literature at that time I was
like shocked at how overtly racist
liberal literature was in terms of
trying to diagnose the ills of the black
community and trying to explain why
these uprisings were happening and
everyone was blaming it on the fathers
and drugs and families and welfare and
mothers and everything it was a lot more
convenient for
the story to be told that black people
weren't holding up their end of the
bargain rather than acknowledging that
America wasn't holding up its end of the
bargain the Moynihan report ultimately
created three camps the liberal camp
which saw the report as a foundation for
policy change the conservative camp
which saw the report as a justification
for the argument that black communities
were responsible for their own issues
and then the left-wing camp that saw the
report as blaming the victim ignoring
structural racism and actually
reinforcing racism so what happens when
people are exposed to these stereotypes
about black families aside from the
reinforcement of the idea that black
communities have no one to blame but
themselves
there's the everyday real-life impact
these stereotypes have through policies
and support for those policies first
there's an almost total willful
ignorance about the impact of slavery
and modern-day incarceration on black
American families foundationally slavery
ripped apart black families and mass
incarceration has put one in twelve
black men between the ages of 25 and 54
in prison versus one in 64 non black
groups then there's how these
characterizations of black American
families have an impact on policies that
affect all Americans take poverty for
instance during the Great Depression era
the face of poverty was a white man who
was down on his luck or a white family
fallen victim to circumstances outside
their control and the country felt a
duty to end poverty namely with
President Franklin D Roosevelt New Deal
then decades later dr. Martin Luther
King jr. began to shed light on the
reality of poor black American families
living in cities and the reporters who
followed him began to report on these
issues
and rundown dilapidated rat-infested
shacks and slaw and as a result of that
over time all of the imagery began to
focus on these black families and it
began to actually have a pernicious
impact it began to help us think of
poverty and black families as tied to
this issue of black laziness and that's
where we largely find ourselves today
according to Pew more than half of
Republicans believe a lack of effort is
to blame for poverty instead of
circumstances beyond one's control as
the conversation on poverty and race
shifted so did the support for welfare
people began to think that we needed to
curb welfare benefits increase work
requirements because the real problem is
that black people are on welfare and
they want to just be lazy when we think
about policies what's good for families
we tend to think about them in these
racialized terms and when we do that we
tend to have a distorted view of what
needs to happen so what's the solution
well here's what Dickson and Wallace had
to say the main way that the media
perpetuates stereotypes and racist
tropes is accidentally I think the
people who are in the decision-making
rooms and the content making rooms are
carrying these biases with them without
knowing they're carrying them with them
because there's no one around to
challenge them so I think that
ultimately greater diversity at all
levels of decision-making in the media
and content process is probably our best
chance of dealing with this as an
african-american father myself as a
father of twin sons I take pride in in
that role and I know many many other
black fathers who take pride in being
involved with their kids regardless of
the marital situation with the mother
and so I really would like the media to
show some of those stories as well
ultimately I'm raising my kids to be a
part of the solution rather than a part
of the problem you know that's really
all I can do so we focused on the way
the news media talks about black
families and black fathers but there's
no shortage of the same representation
in entertainment take for example one of
our favorite scenes of all time from The
Fresh Prince of bel-air
you know exactly which one I'm talking
about so let us know in the comments
below what you guys think where else
you've encountered this
and tune in next week when we come at
you with another great video